uh Yan ven Bran who is my academic
sibling we were both advised by Neon uh
Yan is now um uh assistant professor at
Georgia Tech he has been working a lot
on D Dynamic data structure for metrix
like using metrix data structure to get
a lot of really cool application to LP
and also dyamic graph and today you will
see the application of this for momod FL
and LP I guess thanks um yeah so this is
Joint work with Daniel Jang PhD student
at juder Tech um let me start with some
basic definitions what kind of problems
are we going to look at at this talk so
the first problem is uh I'm going to
call this single commodity flow but
really these are the typical flow
problems as you know them things like
Max flow or mincost flow so you have a
graph with capacities you fix some
Source vertex s and Target vertex T and
you want to find the largest flow that
you can route in this network from s to
T So This Here For example would be a
maximum
flow and
um we're also going to look at something
uh called multicommodity flow let's say
here we have two Commodities so this is
a two commodity flow instance the
difference is that now instead of
routing one flow we're trying to route
two or more Flows at the same time so we
have multiple source and sync Pairs and
the important part here is that any flow
that starts at this green Source s must
reach also the green Target right so
it's not okay if I route some flow from
this green source to the blue Target
that's not
valid and here we're looking for example
for the maximum flow like in the sum of
the two flows maximize the sum of flows
from s to T but you could also ask
things like the Min cost variant where
every vertex has some demand what would
be the the flow in this network then
that minimizes the cost if you also have
costs on the
edges okay so this is kind of the
generalization here of single commodity
flow to multiple
Commodities the last problem we're going
to look at is oh before I go to that um
in this talk I want to focus on
something we call the high accuracy
regime so for m commodity flows there
are so-called low accuracy algorithms
these scale in poly one/ Epsilon where
Epsilon is like your accuracy parameter
and when we want to look at the high
accuracy regime here we want that our
complexity dependence on Epsilon is just
logarithmic so po log one/ Epsilon
instead of just polinomial and one/
Epsilon and um we're also going to focus
on the case where we allow fractional
Solutions because if you try to restrict
to integer Solutions the problem becomes
NP hard and then well we we probably
can't have any efficient algorithms for
that okay so that's um the high accuracy
multicommodity flow problem we going to
look
at the last problem I'm going to look at
are linear programs so here you have a
bunch of linear constraints and you want
to minimize a linear cost function and
linear program is kind of a
generalization of the two previous cases
right you can model flow problems as
linear programs you can just say
something like for every vertex the
entire flow that goes into the vertex
and out of the vertex must be zero for
every vertex except for the start and
sync and you have these constraints for
both flows and you want that the
capacities are satisfied for the sum of
the two
flows so we can model these previous two
problems like single commodity and
multic commodity flows easily as a
linear
program and um yeah that directly gives
us some obvious hierarchy right we can
say that okay single commodity flows
they are captured by multic commodity
flows and they are then captured by
linear
programs and um this order of hardness
we can also see in the algorithms so for
single commodity flow right Min cost
flow Max flow there was recently this
almost linear time algorithm we can
solve this very
efficiently um the fastest algorithm
that I'm going to talk about in this
talk is uh quite a lot slower than
single commodity flow but it's still
faster than if you solve a general
linear program so that would be
something like m to the Omega here Omega
is the matrix multiplication exponent
something like
2.38
roughly uh and throughout this talk I'm
going to hide poly log complexity
terms okay
now those of you who have seen things
like the recent almost linear time
algorithm you probably know that okay
these recent algorithms they all use
these continuous optimization methods
together with data structures from
Dynamic graph
area and the same is also true for this
multic commodity flow algorithm that I'm
going to talk about and it's actually
quite surprising that for multicommodity
flows you can use graph techniques and
that's what I want to outline next why
is it actually surprising that you could
use graph techniques for multicommodity
flows so let's look at the brief history
of multicommodity
flows so back in the 60s it was shown
that okay if you allow FR for fractional
Solutions you can have a polinomial Time
algorithm and later in the 80s kamaka
came up with this Central path method
for solving linear programs in
polinomial time and that was very
efficient and you can just apply that
linear program solver to the linear
program that models K commodity flow and
then you get some relatively fast
multicommodity flow algorithm and since
this algorithm here by
kamaka every single Improvement is just
the faster linear program solver so we
have repeatedly improved linear program
solvers and since you can solve
multicommodity flow using linear
programs we also get these faster multic
commodity flow
algorithms the important part here is
that right these are not strictly
speaking multicommodity flow algorithms
right they're not graph algorithms
there's no graph technique going on
they're just linear program solvers that
you apply to a certain kind of linear
program and that is super different from
what happened in um single commodity
case rightman and showed that laian
systems can be efficiently solved and
that immediately implied that a whole
whole bunch of continuous optimization
algorithms became more efficient um and
then it was shown also that let's say
these continuous optimization methods if
you have a specific kind of graph
problem like the line by uh MRI atol and
Leo and sit they have shown that the
number of iterations of these continuous
methods can actually be decreased if you
have a flow problem and then there are
all these recent lines of work where
data structures from Dynamic graph area
were used to reduce the time per
iteration uh which ultimately led to
this almost linear time algorithm so for
single commodity flows a whole bunch of
graph techniques were used to get these
very efficient algorithms but somehow
none of this could be transferred to the
multic commodity case we've developed
all of these powerful tools for single
commodity flow in somewh we could not
use that for these high accuracy
multicommodity flow
algorithms
yes K this is constant K yes um I think
all of these should have K
2.5 except for this one which has K to
the
Omega it's all polinomial in K but here
I'm assuming constant
in okay so somewhow it looks like multic
commodity flow is kind of different from
single commodity even though you're just
adding one extra kind of flow in your
graph and that was studied like why is
that different there was some kind of
hardness results that suggest this is
not just coincidence so back in the 70s
itai showed
that any linear program the task of uh
solving that exactly can be reduced to
solving a two commodity flow instance
exactly and recently Ding King and Jang
they have extended this to this high
accuracy regime where you're allowed to
have some approximate Solutions
what that means is that well every
multicommodity flow algorithm that
solves it to high accuracy is a linear
program solver right because you can
just take your linear program transfer
it into a two commodity instance and
then use one of these algorithms yes the
running time of the reduction what is
the running time of the uh the running
time is uh near linear
yeah and uh also the the output so
basically for every nonzero entry in the
linear program you're creating like
poorly log number of
edges Exact
Solutions does this give exact solution
um so this down here does not give Exact
Solutions because this is just for this
high accuracy regime the upper one does
give Exact Solutions
yeah and does the approximation
translate or not does the approximation
translate um
yes it does translate there is two
approximations here one
is um kind of the the optimization value
that you get is only like an additive
Epsilon away from the optimal and also
the constraints like we saying something
like a * X is equal to B there is like a
small error that is like an additive in
epsilon
times I think it's like the fous norm of
the Matrix or something like that um so
for Pol
conditioned linear
programs everything just translates
directly
yeah
okay so this gives now an explanation
why are all the multicommodity flow
algorithms linear program solvers well
because well by this reduction they are
linear program solvers they can be used
to solve linear
programs
um but that also kind of suggests that
yeah maybe we can't use graph techniques
to get faster
algorithms because think about it you
have a linear program maybe that linear
program does not have any kind of graph
structure it doesn't reflect any kind of
graph
problem why would you expect graph
techniques to now result in a faster
algorithm if you could graph techniques
to improve multicommodity flow
algorithms there's a CIA to this idea
though and that
is these are sparse graphs that are
being produced by this
reduction so means maybe you can use
graph techniques to get faster
algorithms on dense graphs and be sure
that this is indeed true if you have a
dense graph we can use graph-based
Dynamic algorithm techniques to improve
the uh linear program solver complexity
which is M like the number of edges to
the Omega down to root M * n
omegaus the first Improvement for
multicommodity flow here that actually
does use graph techniques and it kind of
implies that yeah maybe multicommodity
flow was actually more graph theoretic
more combinatorial in structure than we
previously thought it's not completely
equivalent to uh linear program
solving and this doesn't improve General
LP because the reduction increases the
precisely it does not improve General LP
because well it's always creating a
sparse graph if the number of edges and
vertices is the same well both the Old
and the new algorithm just run in N
Omega time no improvement there yes
okay and that is basically the the
summary of the the main conceptual
message here that previously all
improvements for multicommodity flow
they were just linear program solvers
improved linear program solvers no graph
techniques were being used here and um
there were also heartness results that
suggested that yeah okay maybe you can
just get improvements using faster LP
techniques fast algebraic techniques and
so on but now we show that actually you
can use graph techniques to get
something more efficient because the
hardness was really just for sparse
graphs and uh in particular that means
multicommodity flow in this High accous
regime might be more combinator and more
graph theoretic than we previously
thought other questions so far before I
go more into technical
ideas
okay so what are the data structures
what are the graph techniques we're
using
here so
we are using something that's called the
central path method and you can just
think of that as reduction it says if
you want to solve some linear program
then you can reduce that to solving a
sequence of linear systems and the nice
thing is that the first linear system
and then the second and the third like
the sequence it's slowly changing so the
linear systems are kind of similar any
two consecutive ones so that's precisely
where you would want to use some kind of
dynamic algorithm that just maintains
the solution of of your linear
system and in previous work two Central
data structure problems were identified
uh in fact in this paper there's
basically a reduction that says if you
get data structures with certain update
and query complexities you get a LP
solver with certain complexities so if
you wanted to you could just write data
structure papers and get maybe faster LP
solvers um one data structure problem is
about Matrix inversion that's kind of
algebraic that doesn't really have
anything to do with graphs so I'm going
to skip over that in this
talk what I want to focus on is
something called The Heavy hitter
problem let me quickly outline what this
problem
is so you're given a matrix it's kind of
a tall Matrix and what you want to do is
you want to compute a matrix Vector
product um now the nice thing is we
don't need to compute the entire Matrix
Vector product all I care about are the
large entries so you PR process your
Matrix and then you have a query
operation where you get a vector H and
some threshold T all I want to know is
which entries of this Matrix Vector
product are larger than the threshold I
don't care about the small numbers the
small entries of this
product and it's slightly dynamic in
that um we want to have some kind of
delete operation where we can remove one
of these uh rows of Matrix
a if you can solve this if efficiently
then you're actually going to improve
linear program solving as
well okay now there is an interesting uh
Insight here and that is all the
provable hardness for multicommodity
flows and provable hardness for linear
programs in
general is kind of captured by this
inverse maintenance there is currently
no formal argument why this heavy hitter
problem should be impossible to solve
using graph
techniques
and you all work here or the majority
here works on dynamic graphs you
probably multiply matrices with vectors
all the time right we use things like
the omv conjecture to argue hardness and
so on uh think of something like one
step in a random B you have some
probability distribution uh the
probabilities of your random B there's
tons of graph problems that can be
modeled by these Matrix Vector products
so we can actually use graph techniques
here to get an efficient data structure
for this Matrix Vector product and we
show that at least for multicommodity
flow that is true um but I'm just just
conjecturing here I wouldn't be
surprised if that would also be true for
General Spar linear programs that maybe
you could actually use graph techniques
there because all the provable hardness
is in this other data structure task for
him heavy hitter you might actually be
able to use graph techniques in
general um so it's kind of my open
problem that I bring here for this
Workshop question yes um like why like
do you need to do anything about the
delete operation if you need to do
anything here so
um it might get become more clear on the
next slide why I care about the delete
operation so let's uh wait with this
question I go to the next slide maybe
that's going to be answered so the
question was why do we need the delete
operation
here so I said right this is the problem
the complexity we are hoping for is the
following so this is the open the
precise open problem The Matrix a you're
given and that you're pre-processing is
a star Matrix you can assume something
like K non zeros per
row and we would want that the
initialization is linear in the number
of rows you have and it's fine if you
have some polom in K some small polom in
k um delete operation should also be
polinomial in K and
the the important part is for the query
operation we want that the query
operation scales in this term this is
the L2 Norm of a * h
s divid by t² this Factor here you can
think of that as like a worst case bound
on how many entries in my Matrix Vector
product are actually larger than
T So this B tells you kind of how many
entries we expect to return and but if
you have a delete operation then over
time this gets smaller so your query
operation also needs to become more
efficient needs to spend less
time
okay if you could solve this just
blackbox you plug it into like the
reductions of previous work it
immediately implies that you have a spar
tall LP solver so any linear program
that has like lots of
constraints you can solve in basically M
times poly K time and some small
polinomial in N uh here n is the width
so you can think of it as once this is
tall
enough this first term is going to
dominate
anyway um in particular think of
something like you have just poly log
nonzeros per row that would be basically
nearly linear time LP solver for these
sparse linear programs we don't know how
to do this efficiently that's the major
open problem that we are left with
solving and answers to this open problem
we only have for very specific special
cases if a is a very dense Matrix like
it's not Spar it's just that let's say
every entry is nonzero you can solve
linear programs in MN Time by basically
solving this heavy hitter problem
specifically for dense matrices so
there's a data structure for that
special case there's also a data
structure for the special case where
your Matrix is an incidence matrix it's
an incidence Matrix you can also solve
this efficiently that immediately
implies that any LP that uses incidence
matrices like next flow uh bipartite
matching and so on they can be solved in
this near linear time complexity
assuming have at least into 1.5
CES so cases we know how to solve it but
in practice most linear programs are
sparse so this is actually not all that
efficient for most uh linear programs as
they occur in practice we want to have
something that's more efficient on
sparse
matrices and this is just the main open
problem we have to solve just this one
single data structure problem then we're
done
okay and yeah I'm conjecturing that
maybe we can use graph techniques to
solve this
in the case of multicommodity flow we
could at least prove that this is
actually true you can use graph
techniques
here questions to this open problem
before I go to some sketch proof
sketch so here's an incomplete proof
that doesn't work and then we're going
to fix
it let's say this is our T Matrix a and
the vector and we want to figure out the
large entries without loss of General I
can assume that every nonzero entry that
I have In Here Also occurs in again but
negated I can just say append minus a
and my Vector I'm appending zero it's
still the same Matrix Vector product
right because I'm just multiplying zeros
with this a
minus so I can just assume that every
entry occurs positive and
negative that's almost the structure of
an incidence Matrix right I can just say
okay let's look always at the first
non-zero entry in every row and the
corresponding negated one and put that
into an incidence Matrix this is now a
weighted incidence matrix it's not just
plus one minus one it's more like plus
weight minus weight and I can do this
for the first nonzero entry and then
again for the second nonzero entry and
so on assuming I have K nonzero entries
I can say the product a * H is just the
sum of these incident matrices and the
vector H Prime where H Prime is just the
original Vector with zeros
appended so instead of General matrices
I just look at incidence
matricies question yeah I I lost
something there's just one instance
Matrix or there several there are K
different ones I'm assuming this Matrix
a has K nonzero entries each row each
pair of of of nonzeros corresponding to
a single Dart a single yes every uh pair
of non-zero entries in a row corresponds
to like one Edge in one of these
matrices it's a sum of it's a sum of
right the sum of these
matri so now I have incidence
matrices um and I can say all right um
instead of asking is an entry larger
than T in my original product I could
just ask is any one entry of these terms
in my sum larger than T over K if I find
all these indices then I in particular
found all of the indices where a times H
is larger so I can restrict myself to
incidence matrices and that is really
just a graph problem what I'm saying
here is I have potentials on the
vertices and then I'm asking like the
which edges carry large electric flow
when I'm looking at the graph that is
represented by these uh rated incidence
matrices so it's really just a graph
problem that I'm looking at here I can
at this point ignore all of the
algebra this doesn't work though anyone
sees an issue
here you see an issue yes cancellations
across the right we could have
cancellations here it could happen that
maybe an entry here in a * H is zero or
very close to zero I don't care about
that entry however it could be that
let's say B1 and B2 if I compute
these products here they're a very large
positive and a very large negative value
they just happen to cancel in the sum
here so it could be that I'm returning
way too many indices and just returning
one index but I have to write that down
in memory that takes time so it could be
that this is actually too
slow so the problem is in general this
might be too slow you might be returning
too many indices uh in particular right
we wanted that the complexity of the
query operation scales in this L2 Norm
here of a * H but now the complexity is
actually going to scale in several
smaller L2 norms and um just by like
triangle inequality that could be way
larger
right so it doesn't quite work
yet summary here is this heavy hitter
problem on sparse matrices we could try
to phrase that as a graph problem
something like given vert
potentials which edges carry a lot of
electric
flow uh but this if we just do it
naively comes with a complexity blow up
uh the complexity of our data structure
scales in the sum of these L2 Norms
which could just be much larger
potentially than the torm of the sum
which is precisely the norm that we
wanted to have our complexity scale in
that's the problem we have and um I'm
going to show that in the special case
of multicommodity flows that can be
fixed the main question here is can we
fix that for other matrices as well is
there a different class of sparse
matrices that maybe we can now solve
linear programs on more efficiently
using some kind of graph
technique okay uh other questions
continue
no okay so the special case of uh K
commodity flows what we're going to look
at are so-called K commodity incidence
matrices and with a similar reduction as
the one before I'm going to reduce it to
regular incidence
matrices just as a reminder a regular
incidence Matrix right it's a matrix
where every row corresponds to an edge
and you can just say you have plus that
edge rate and minus that H rate in every
row now K commodity incidence Matrix is
this thing generalized but your Edge
rates are not numbers anymore The Edge
rates that you have are actually small K
byk
mates so I'm saying here okay for every
Edge I have a block of K
rows and it contains a block that is
some weight Matrix W and a negated
weight Matrix
W so similar to the previous example I
have this nice property that every entry
that occurs in some positive form also
occurs in a negative form so I can do
the similar trick as before of splitting
this into smaller incidence
matrices um but now I have some extra
structural guarantees onto these for
these K non zero entries I can use these
to kind of bound these Norm issues that
I had
previously so what we're going to do is
right we have this Matrix Vector problem
where K consecutive rows kind of look
like this here
everything is zero except for these K
byk
blocks but now I'm just going to reorder
The
Matrix B reordering rows and columns as
follows Um this can be seen as kind of
like an incidence Matrix but every entry
is a k byk block I can say well that's
actually a k byk block where every uh
smaller block is an incidence Matrix
just by reordering rows and columns uh
basically for every Edge take the top
left nonzero
entry those are now my uh edges that I
plug into this top left incidence Matrix
I do this for every non-zero entry so
the top right entry that corresponds now
to an edge I put in the top right
block so this is just my reordering of
rows and columns and then my Matrix
Vector product is still just a matrix
Vector product the nice thing is I now
have all of these small incidence
matrices
now I can yes uh do we have some
structure in this small Matrix in the
small Matrix we have some structure I
will mention you know I can actually
write it down if I have a pen
here ah thank you okay the structure is
roughly as follows
um let's say I have some small K
dimensional
vector
small K dimensional vector
v um I believe it needs to be positive
entry
Bice now we look at the Matrix that
is the diagonal matrix with v on the
diagonal so
can and plug V onto this diagonal and
then I'm
subtracting uh V * V trans
ose divided by I think it's the one NM
squar it was similar to this I not 100%
sure if there was a square here or if
maybe there was another division by k or
something like that but this is roughly
the structure it's like a diagonal
matrix minus an outer
product so it is a full rank Matrix but
it kind of has this nice spasy
presentation okay
um right so asking is there a large
entry in a * I is really the same as
asking okay is there one entry that is
larger than T over
K one of these smaller
products but now I come in get into the
same issue as before right if I now just
run the heavy hitter problem on K Square
incidence matrices couldn't it be that
they return way too many entries here
compared to above here because of some
cancellations of positive and negative
numbers and
um yeah there is a solution here
which let's say it this way I tried to
solve this for months I couldn't solve
it I gave it to my student and over the
weekend he said it works if you just
replace it by this
term why here is one page calculation
that proves it works we don't actually
know why it works other than being able
to verify it
um would be nice to get more intuition
here but at least I can prove that it's
correct all right um one of the special
structures is
that um let's see if that follows from
me I hope it does the sum of these uh
incidence matrices is equal to
zero so if I have this extra HL here
which is always multiplied with b and I
have a sum of a j I'm really just adding
a zero here so this and this is
equivalent I've just added an extra zero
and it turns out that
apparently these two electric flows like
the flow of B time HJ and the flow of B
time
HL are similar enough that if I now look
at the electric flow of these with the
difference in these
potentials that's much
smaller so I can now look at uh where do
I have entries here that are larger than
T over K and um Daniel my my co-author
has proven that okay the sum of these L2
Norms is at most six
times the L2 Norm outside of the sum
which is like six times the original the
original problem now note that these
here add up precisely to a * H so in a
sense if we ignore the six here right
that would kind of be the Pythagorean
theorem that
says these flows these vectors are kind
of almost orthogonal to each
other so the main question here is can
we find for other matrices this near
orthogonal decomposition into electric
flows if we could do that we could get
faster linear program solvers on that
kind of
Matrix so it's like a page of
calculation that I'm not going to
include here in this top
uh it follows from assuming I didn't
make an error in defining the Matrix but
it would follow from this
here so the summary here is the heavy
hitter task on
this more dense multicommodity incidence
Matrix where you have Kon zero entries
can be reduced regular incidence
matricies and that's done by splitting
this original product of a * H into K
Square almost orthogonal electric flows
so now we have a graph problem we can
then use graph data structures to solve
this um and the question is okay can we
get Heavy Hitters on more General sparse
matrices because when we would get
linear program solvers on more General
kind of Spar matrices and maybe we can
even use graph techniques
here okay next I will explain how to
actually solve it on in matrices what
are the actual graph techniques we're
going to use
here other
questions yes what did you use uh from
the fact that it's a it's a multic
commodity in what did I use from the
fact that it's a multicommodity flow
weight Matrix
um if I recall correctly the uh
multicommodity weight Matrix looks like
this some diagonal minus uh these other
parts that kind of gives you let let's
say correlations between different rows
right if you think of this as
a a matrix you kind of know there is a
certain correlation between this row and
the other row because so the diagonals
are coming from the non zero WDS right
for the barrier for f i
being non negative and the V are coming
from saying that their sum
is their sum is small you mean with
respect to if you look at the barrier
method why is that the precise weight
just just aligning that the V that the V
are coming from the fact that there's
some constraint gives you this right
right um You you can think of these V's
as something like a if you wanted to
solve single commodity flow you have
these electric flows on and you use like
one of one of the SL as the resistance
these are kind of your new
resistances um this guarantees that um
basically your your flow stays positive
and this guarantees that uh while you're
not shooting over the capacities because
they are multiple flows on the same
Edge so that might be a
plus now I think it's actually a minus
and the normalization was important to
make sure that this stays
PSD
okay
thanks
um right
so it might look slightly different uh
but roughly like this uh and using that
you can then use this nonbound can prove
this okay um yeah what are the graph
techniques we use
so we said we have this heavy hitter
problem you pre-process an incidence
Matrix and then we get some vector and
we want to figure out which entries are
larger than
T that can be phrased as a graph problem
where we say we given given a graph G
with some Edge rates and um then we have
some query Vector H and we want to get
all the edges where the difference is
larger than T let's assume for
Simplicity here that all the edges have
weight one because what you could just
do is uh round things to nearest powers
of two and split it into log many
problems so let's assume for now graph
is
unwed then we are now trying to solve
this problem here
let's look at a very simple naive
algorithm for this what we could do is I
just iterate over my vertices and check
is one of these end points larger than T
over2 if that's the case return all the
incident edges to this
vertex in this case I'm definitely
returning all the edges where the
difference is larger than T but I might
be actually returning too many indices
for a similar reason as before it could
be that maybe h and HV are both very
large but then the difference happens to
be equal to zero I would return that
edge with this naive
algorithm so how can we fix this naive
algorithm and uh yeah expanders are
going to solve this issue for
us what we're going to do is we use the
expander decomposition where given a
graph G you can split it into small
expander graphs
and for expanders we have this jiger
inequality that uh basically tells us
for any Vector that's orthogonal to the
degree Vector we have this equality here
and this now allows us to bound the
complexity of that native algorithm what
we can do is on each expander that we
have first shift Ed by the all on Vector
so it becomes orthogonal to the degree
Vector not that I can just shift by the
all1 vector without problem because I
wanted to figure out which edges uh have
large
difference I want to know where's the
difference larger than T So if I shift
both these by the same amount I'm not
changing
anything so I can just shift H by the
all1 vector and then eventually if I
shift it enough it becomes orthogonal to
the degree
vector and now I do this naive algorithm
where I just iterate over all the
vertices check if the value on that
vertex is larger than t/2 if that's the
case return everything incident through
that vertex within that
expander okay so what's the complexity
here this here is about on the
complexity right over for every expander
we iterate over all the vertices and
then check okay is HV larger than T if
that's the case we return all the edges
returning all the edges costs the degree
of the vertex right you can think of
that as something that's uh larger than
the the indicator Vector of you're
returning everything if HB is larger
than T this fraction is larger
than so this is a bound on the
complexity
here and well we now directly apply this
CH inequality which tells us that's up
to poly log factors the same as looking
at the differences squared divided by T
Square which precisely is incidence
Matrix times the vector H over t² that's
precis the complexity we are hoping for
complexity that scales in the L2 Norm of
the
vector so on incidence matrices we can
solve this problem efficiently using the
expanded decomposition the expanded
decomposition can be made Dynamic with
this pruning technique so this operation
can also be
supported right as a
reminder this L2 Norm really is just the
worst case bound on how many edges would
you have to return anyway so it turns
out up to a polog factor we're not even
returning more edges than you would
expect anyway even though we're using
this naive algorithm of just returning
all incident
edges so to summarize um previously
multicommodity flow algorithms they were
all linear program solvers uh there were
no graph techniques being used in this
high accuracy regime and it was shown
that multicommodity flows as hard as
general linear programs so any LP can be
reduced to a multicommodity flow
instance um and we show that you can
actually use graph techniques we develop
this heavy hitter data structure for
matrices as they occur in the
multicommodity flow
problem and open problems would be on
one hand can you improve the algorithm
further can you get matrix
multiplication time that scales only in
the number of
vertices and is it possible to improve
this heavy hitter problem for more
General sparse
matrices it might be possible that using
graph techniques we can actually proove
something here because all the hardness
proofs that we have kind of captured
with this Matrix uh inverse maintenance
part maybe we can use graph techniques
to to solve SP
problems
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for
y do your heavy heiter need to be
adaptive or just oblivious to aniversary
so if it works against oblivious
adversaries if the heavy hitter data
specture works against oblivious
adversaries that's already enough in the
sense that um if the data structure is
correct it definitely returns all the
indices that have large entry so the
whole obliviousness the whole Randomness
can only mean that you're returning too
many indices but then you can just check
every index should we return that does
it actually cross the threshold t or not
so you can say with high probability
after this extra filtering your data
structure coincides with some
deterministically defined uh
structure thank
you
okay so I mean you're interested in
maybe more General LPS but if say just
two commodity or k
commodity is it possible to sort of like
interpret this in a
more simpler way or maybe interest
interpreting of what's going on here um
I mean some kind of a explicitly a
computation of electrical flow of one
commodity and cycling through or
something I don't know if there is any
possible
so my interpretation of what's going on
here but it's not entirely accurate
would be that um this augmenting flow
that's computed in every iteration we're
kind of splitting that into smaller
electric flows that's at least what
we're doing for this heavy hitter
problem though it's not entirely
accurate because um laan systems are
easy to solve but multicommodity laion
as in you have two multic commodity
incidence matrices and you multiply them
together to get this multic commodity
laion there as hard to solve as general
linear systems so it's unlikely that you
can split this laion system
into that you can split this multic
commodity laan system into smaller
regular laan systems so it's not
entirely accurate to say that the
splitting the augmenting flow in just
electric
flows just for the last heavy hitter
part given some kind of vertex
potentials is splitting that into small
electric
FL all right then uh thanks a lot
[Applause]
Yan so that would conclude today